from above the scale of the destruction
in solidar is clear and so is the danger
smoke billows above buildings as
Ukrainian armored vehicle weaves through
what's left of the Eastern Ukrainian
town on a mission to evacuate injured
servicemen
Ukrainian military officials say the
situation in solidar is critical but
that their soldiers are holding on
the situation is difficult but stable we
are holding back the enemy nobody leaves
the positions we are fighting back some
ukrainians fighting in solidar say they
need more ammunition and backup
Ukraine's President says that they'll
get everything that they need
we have analyzed in detail the decisions
needed the reinforcements needed and the
steps to be taken by commanders in the
coming days
we have also discussed the situation
with the supply of weapons and
ammunition to the Troops
for months solidar has been the scene of
Relentless and intense fighting
but Russia's defense Ministry now says
its forces have taken solidar
on the evening of January 12 The
Liberation of the city of solidar was
complete which is important for the
continuation of successful offensive
operations in the Donetsk region
earlier Russian mercenary group Wagner
posted a video online saying that its
Fighters were already in town
Russia has focused on taking solidars
part of a push to capture the entire
Eastern Ukrainian donbass region but it
has come at a very high price Russian
and Ukrainian losses have been high for
civilians the situation has been
devastating most people have fled
solidar but more than 500 people remain
including children Ukrainian forces are
racing to try to evacuate them while
there's still time Natasha Butler Al
Jazeera Kiev